une affaire dont on n'a pas fini de
reparler autre chose ce soir à 22h25 sur
antenne 2 le magazine de daniel leconte
l'histoire immédiate avec cette question
faut-il avoir peur des croyants une
question d'actualité au moment où
ressurgissent au grand jour toutes les
religions et bien sûr entre foi
religieuse et fanatisme
il n'y a qu'une étroite frontières qu'il
est parfois difficile à définir
exemples très concrets qui se posent
dans certains lycées et collèges en ce
moment par exemple dans ce collège à
creil
trois jeunes filles musulmanes qui
s'opposent à leurs professeurs et aux
dirigeants du collège motif elles
veulent afficher en permanence les
signes extérieurs de leur religion
chantal kimmerlin yanncik l enquête
l'objet du délit le foulard plus
précisément le dif marocain que porte
fatima et leïla
selon leurs convictions musulmane et je
crains en dieu je crains de personne
sauf que dieu sait pas ce que ça vous
plaise que ma mort fatima et leïla ont
14 et 13 ans elle étudie le coran chez
elle au tableau noir depuis l'âge de 3
ans elles font leurs cinq prières par
jour mais leur but dans la vie c'est
aussi de réussir à l'école
moi je veux continuer mes études je
travaillais fatima et les là ne sont pas
exclues du collège georges a vez mais
l'accès leur en ai refusé tant qu'elles
porteront le foulard pendant les cours
principe de laïcité oblige le problème
n'est pas des croyances le problème est
de la manifestation extérieure de cette
croyance dans l'enceinte des locaux
scolaires notamment en classe
le collège classé en zone d'éducation
prioritaire compte 850 élèves de 25
nationalités différentes dont 500
musulmans
le problème c'est de vivre en
collectivité et conformément à la notion
de neutralité politique ou religieuse un
corso faut largement demande voici les
jeunes qui le cas puisque ce foulard est
qu un père qui lui aussi part de
tolérance et ni faire pression sur syfy
ya second volet c'est pas moins de
problèmes si méfiez vous
le connaît aujourd'hui est celle de paul
à moi je n'ai aucun moyen
vous ne le forcez pas à brac absolument
pour la première fois aujourd'hui un
mois après la rentrée scolaire le
dialogue s'est engagé entre le père des
jeunes filles est le principal du
collège est dialogue difficile qui peut
être ouvrira sur une solution